people will i assure them people will
feel lied to and manipulated when they
go back and watch the long-form videos
and they're very used to that feeling
because they've been lied to and
manipulated for two years about covid so
they've been lied to they've been and
then they go and they do their own
research and they're like wait a second
this is like not yet you still may
disagree with some i still find myself
we'll bring something up at the end of
the show today where i do disagree with
him and that's okay
like i don't need to agree with him on
everything i don't need to agree with
him on everything it's not necessary
we're both you know free thinking people
we can have a difference of opinion on
something there's nothing wrong with
that but these people who are threatened
by others right to an opinion that's
that's a really big problem and i i hate
i mean i have i always say my little boy
is two and a half the world he's gonna
be in in another 15 years i don't even
know man if we don't do something
because it's a mess